[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія, а мене
звати, о, давай, MA, привіт, давайте почнемо
сьогодні, ми продовжуємо говорити про здоровий
спосіб життя, і я хотів би, щоб ви
почали  з головоломкою, тож подивіться на
екран зараз, і ми дамо вам лише 50
секунд, спробуйте знайти принаймні одне слово
і згадайте, яке буде вашим
першим словом, яке ви побачите
[Музика]
добре, давайте перевіримо разом, тому  Ольга,
яке слово ти добре побачила, як тільки я
подивився на екран я побачив слово
усвідомлення,
мабуть, тому що ти уважний я побачив
лінь, можливо, тому, що я хочу бути лінивим
сьогодні,
можливо, я не знаю, але давайте перевіримо
всі слова, які  ви можете знайти тут, у
головоломці, зараз ми даємо вам одну хвилину, спробуйте
знайти якомога більше слів
[Музика]
готові перевірити давайте, тому ми
вже згадали про усвідомленість та
лінь подорожі, тож давайте іншими
словами я бачу сором'язливість, що  ти бачиш
Ольга смуток я також бачу слабкість
w  ще наше щастя добре ввічливість я
бачу божевілля фантастичний тому давайте перевіримо
ще раз
лінь смуток щастя божевілля
слабкість сором'язливість ввічливість уважність
Браво
молодець, тож давайте сьогодні зосередимося на цих
словах Наталія, я помітив, що всі
ці слова є іменниками так, ви маєте рацію,
і ми  сьогодні ми будемо говорити про
прикметники, як я сказав вам
уважність уважний лінь ледачий добре, тому
ми говорили про тіло, душу та розум, у
нас був урок зі спорту про сон та
їжу, тому ми охопили частину тіла, а тепер
давайте зосередимося на своєму розумі,
тому  назва уроку буде
усвідомленість то що це за усвідомленість
Ольга як ви можете описати цю
усвідомленість це, мабуть, коли ви
розумієте, що ви робите, як ви відчуваєте, що
ви хочете робити, а що не
хочете робити добре давайте перевіримо  з їх
визначенням, тож подивіться на екран і
прочитайте разом з нами.
Усвідомленість – це практика усвідомлення свого тіла, розуму та
почуттів у даний момент,
що створює  відчуття спокою, тобто бути
присутнім у даний момент, що
означає бути присутнім у даний момент, ми зараз тут
, ми усвідомлюємо, добре
не завжди іноді я можу бути присутнім
тут, але в моїй думці я десь
далеко  можливо, планую вечерю для моєї
Емілі, можливо, плануєш мій відпочинок, можливо,
просто не щасливий, що я зараз тут,
я бачу, тож давайте подивимося відео про те, як
бути присутнім у цей момент, давайте з
нами, літаємо з Абелем, а
усвідомленість присутня в
теперішній момент, що
насправді означає бути присутнім, це означає
прислухатися до шуму океанських
хвиль, бути присутнім, означає відчувати
вітер у повітрі, бути присутнім, означає
відчувати м'який дотик до
присутній квітки, це приємно, що ти
присутній терпляче чекаєш  тому що ваша
черга в черзі бути присутнім - це
уважно слухати, що говорять інші,
бути присутнім означає допомагати іншим, коли
ви помічаєте, що їм потрібна допомога, присутність
- це зосередитися на своїй класній роботі, а не
коли буде ваша перерва на перерві,
це насолоджуватися кожним
досвідом, оскільки можливість навчитися
бути присутнім означає усвідомити, що
робити помилки,
бути присутнім, бути вдячним за вашу
родину та друзів
[Музика]
, це дозволити собі
відчути своє дихання
[Музика]
бути присутнім - це бути спокійним і дозволити
собі відчути тишу, так що ще раз, які
є варіанти бути присутніми зараз у
цей момент, подивіться на екран, будь ласка,
і читайте разом з нами, слухаючи звуки, що
наповнюють вітер, заповнюють м'який дотик,
бути приємним  Вашим друзям, які терпляче
чекають твоєї черги,
уважно слухають, що
говорять інші, допомагаючи іншим, коли їм потрібна
допомога, зосереджуючись на вашій класній роботі, насолоджуючись
кожним досвідом, усвідомлюючи, що
робити помилки можна, дякуючи,
дозволяючи собі відчути своє дихання
Наталія зараз, коли ми  прочитав
список пропозицій, як бути уважним, що
для вас має бути усвідомленим у даний
момент для m  Це прислухатися
до звуків і відчувати м'який
дотик чогось, наприклад, я бачу цей
прекрасний куб і зосереджуюся на
кольорі, який я бачу, о, це такий жовтий,
це так тепло, тому для
мене це щось важливе і  для мене
це означає зосередитися
на моменті, який у вас є зараз, якщо
ви, наприклад, говорите про урок,
оскільки ми вчителі, ми
говоримо про завдання, що у нас є
текст, який ми читаємо аудіо, яке  ми
слухаємо або музику, яку ми
слухаємо, зосереджуючись на словах
на повідомленні тексту, це для
мене, а
що з тобою Ольга так, я пам'ятаю це,
коли ти в класі, перш
ніж виконувати будь-яку вправу для свого  Студенти
намагаються дати їм завдання пояснити, що
станеться, де вони будуть
читати текст, щоб прослухати аудіо
чи написати якийсь твір, потім
наступне, ймовірно, це зробити
вправу, а потім обов’язково запитати їх,
що  інформація була  про я бачу, то
давайте поекспериментуємо, що ви можете
побачити тут зараз О
клейкі ведмедики так, вони також смачні ведмедики,
так що ви, які кольори ви бачите,
о, я бачу темно-коричневий зелений
жовтий якийсь помаранчевий рожевий я бачу, так що
ж нам робити  зазвичай робимо з ведмедиком
Ямі ведмедика о, ми їх їмо, чи можна мені трохи
так, будь ласка, добре, я помив руки, тому у мене
є пара о, дякую, у мене є гра, у
мене є жовта, у мене є помаранчевий,
фантастичний Приємного апетиту Ольга
мм-хм я  бачу, що ви зараз присутні,
але ви щойно схопили
ведмедів і з'їли їх, так що, Ольга, вам
це сподобалося
о так, було смачно, я бачу, який був на
смак, аромат або два солодкий, я не
отримав смаку, а як щодо форми
Привітні ведмеді - це просто клейкі ведмедики,
я бачу, так що, схоже, Ользі не
сподобався момент, давайте спробуємо ще раз,
ви маєте рацію. Я не дуже думав
про смак, я просто схопив його, поклав його в
рот, і я так швидко його жував
так  без мечів, щоб ти не
пам'ятав, скажімо так, то давайте спробуємо
знову так, я буду уважний, тепер
добре, тому ви візьміть одного ведмедя, оберіть
колір, який ви хотіли б добре смакувати,
тепер я бачу, що є різні
кольори, я вважаю, що вони різні на
смак, звичайно, я люблю виноград, і я
вірю в це  темний темний може бути на
смак винограду добре, я буду обережний
, не поспішайте добре, тому послухайте мої
вказівки, зараз ви збираєтеся покласти
свого ведмедя в рот і намагайтеся не
їсти його або намагайтеся не жувати від
в першу мить спробуйте використовувати рот,
покладіть його на язик і спробуйте язиком спробувати на
смак форму ммм це приємно
і м'яко
добре знайди тіло ммм спробуй знайти
вуха ммм добре тепер почни жувати і
намагайся знайти смак  смак,
як це було
ммм, це насичений смак
це був виноград, напевно виноград я люблю
виноград
я люблю виноградний сік ммм це було дуже
смачно м’яким, і мені дуже сподобався
момент, коли я отримав кращу річ
q чи це відрізнялося від першого
досвіду о  цього
разу
мені було дуже по-іншому  цікаве про те, що
відбувається зі мною, як я відчував, і мені вдалося
це насолоджуватися Мені це дуже сподобалося,
дякую,
і ти виглядаєш щасливим, я можу сказати так,
фантастично, тому щоразу,
коли ви їсте, тепер намагайтеся насолоджуватися кожною миттю, якщо
ви їсте задом наперед
подумайте про форми, коли ви кладете
швидку ложку до рота, спробуйте спробувати
цю форму та перевірити смак,
тому зосередьтесь на моменті, якщо ви
їсте десерт, щось на кшталт смачного,
зосередьтеся на тому, як він виглядає, дивіться
різні кольори, дивіться форми та  тоді спробуйте
тестувати, не поспішайте, насолоджуйтесь кожною
секундою,
так, їжа – це не тільки те, що
дає енергію нашому організму, іноді
спільна їжа може бути чудовим досвідом
із сім’єю друзів, чи не так, я бачу, я
абсолютно згоден  з вами, тож давайте почнемо
з прикметника, який ми щойно
знайшли в головоломці на
початку нашого уроку, тому ми пам’ятали право
ледачий де ще
слабкий сором’язливий ввічливий щасливий сумний фантастичний тепер
давайте утворимо іменники від цих прикметників
ми даємо вам 30 секунд,
тож давайте перевіримо разом я скажу,
що прикметники допоможуть мені з іменником
Annika oh yes давайте спробуємо так уважно
уважність сумний смуток слабкість
сором'язливість сором'язливість ввічлива ввічливість божевільне
щасливе щастя і ледачий або
лінь фантастичний це  було легким завданням,
тому що все, що мені потрібно було зробити, це додати
суфікс Ness, і з вашого прикметника я
створив багато красивих іменників так,
це також можливо, тому перший варіант
- додати суфікс Ness і з'їсти SS, але подивіться
на правило, тепер ми можемо  також додайте E і
C суфікс або a і C e Bravo, тепер давайте
зосередимося на таких іменниках, як
уважність, лінь, сором'язливість, і давайте
подумаємо про протилежне, тож якщо я скажу
лінь, що буде
протилежністю ммм активність фантастична, то
що таке прикметник  від слова іменник
активність активний фантастичний такий активний +
+ e SS активність давайте спробуємо з
іншим, коли ми говоримо божевілля
що буде навпаки Ольга я б
підійшов на серйозність Браво і що таке
прикметник від слова серйозність
серйозний Браво така серйозна серйозність
давайте зі свідком слабкість потужність
потужність Браво і прикметник
потужний фантастичний давайте продовжувати
печаль щастя це легко і бути
прикметником щасливий Браво
давайте з наступним ввічливість о,
я люблю ввічливих людей мені подобаються
ввічливість, але грубі люди грубість
фантастична,
тому прикметник грубий та іменник
грубість давайте використовувати різні варіанти,
тож давайте спробуємо суфікс E і C або a і C,
тому, коли я кажу уважність, що
буде навпаки, я працював би на
невігластво Браво  і давайте подумаємо
про прикметник, це зовсім інший
необізнаний, чи не так, так давайте повторимо
неуцтво невежество Браво,
давайте продовжимо, коли ми скажемо сором'язливість,
що буде навпаки Ольга ах
впевнена впевненість фантастична і ви
вже згадали прикметник
який впевнений  тож давайте ще раз повторимо
впевнену впевненість, тепер ви можете побачити
на екрані прикметники, які намагаються створити
n  іменники від цих прикметників давайте перевіримо
так, Ольга, ти допоможеш мені так перше
слово було розумний так і іменник
буде інтелект сумнів що
означає Тао Тао означає дурний не
дуже розумний хлопець або го скажи чоловік,
який збирається  бути тупістю що
щодо прикметника важливо
це легко важливо хм
готовність готовність нерелевантне що б
нерелевантне означає це не
важливо зараз і це не потрібно
робити зараз це не доречно
нерелевантне невідповідність і останній
повільний це легко повільність тому ми маємо
ще шість іменників правильно, давайте підемо з
протилежностями, тому, коли я говорю інтелект,
що буде протилежністю ммм,
ви згадали темряву фантастично,
це ідеальний збіг,
давайте зважимо важливо не
важливо недоречність
Браво, а останнє – готовність або
повільність так, ми  ми говоримо про
момент, коли ти готовий допомогти,
тому готовність готова допомогти і
повільність я не готовий допомогти
я вагаюся я це  nking wow я бачу
багато туалетів,
що ми будемо робити зараз добре Наталія,
коли ми говоримо про усвідомленість
про присутність тут зараз
я зрозумів, що можу бути
присутнім у той момент, коли я планую
заздалегідь, коли  Я знаю, що
станеться, коли я знаю, чим буде зайнятий мій день,
добре, а
ти, чим зайняті твої дні
, тому я починаю свій день зі
сніданку з приготування їжі, я також
перевірив будинок, тому трохи прибираю
деякі помічники, як роботи, але все-таки я
прибираю, що ще, так що багато справ по
справі добре, добре, дозвольте мені записати
це добре домашні справи так добре
дуже добре
все, що ви робите протягом дня,
так, я також виконую свою роботу,
тому я піду  до офісу я викладаю У мене є
деякі навчальні курси У мене є вебінари
та семінари, тому багато роботи, яку потрібно зробити
протягом дня, добре твоє професійне
життя я буду називати це роботою так, дякую,
наступний блок добре працює, чим ще
ти займаєшся під час  день хм
я також проводжу час зі своїм  сім'я, тому я
проводжу час з дітьми, перевіряйте їх
домашнє завдання, поговоріть з ними, ми разом маємо сімейну
вечерю. Показати дітям час
правильно дуже добре
я поставлю дітей сюди правильно, у нас є кілька
інших блоків, що ви робите,
давайте назвемо це мені час  Гаразд,
я можу прочитати книгу, я також люблю малювати
, тому,
можливо, ти слухаєш музику добре мені будь-які
хобі, які у тебе є кулінарія, звичайно,
я люблю готувати, і це також частина мого
професійного життя, тому кулінарія –
моє найбільше хобі  правильно
готувати тут мені подобається твоє хобі, хм,
готувати дуже добре, ти не згадав
своїх батьків о, так, я також проводив
багато часу зі своїми батьками, тому ми іноді телефонуємо,
ми маємо зустрічі, сімейні
вечері, а також кожен день мама і
тато  грають дуже важливу роль хороша
результативність батьки батьки батьки дуже добре
Наталія, ти встигаєш займатися спортом
не так багато, але так добре, тому у мене
є спорт, давайте цю червону брусок, оскільки
спорт ти прийшов дуже добре
я займаюся плаванням, тому я дуже добре  та  я буду
займатися спортом добре, і я знаю, що цей великий
блок, ймовірно, означає мого чоловіка,
звичайно,
добре, добре, давайте подивимося, що у нас
тут приготування їжі, як твоє хобі, я пам'ятаю,
що добре, робота, у нас є час, у нас є
твоє домашнє господарство, добре, у нас є батьки
у нас є твої діти, ми займаємося спортом і
твій чоловік так добре, це все,
що у тебе добре, насправді є
дрібниці, але іноді це займає весь мій
час О, розкажи мені про це, але перш
ніж почати, дозволь мені зробити щось хороше, то
що це  час, коли ви думаєте, що
ви говорите про це добре, тому, коли мені потрібно
спланувати презентацію для своєї роботи, я починаю
з речей в Інтернеті, тому шукаю
натхнення або мотиваційні зображення, і
здається, що Інтернет займає весь
мій час, тому я почну з одного зображення  потім
перейдіть до відео, а потім продовжте з
обліковими записами в соціальних мережах, і я не можу припинити
перевіряти це, тому серфінг в Інтернеті так
добре, тому це виглядає крихітним, якщо я проводжу багато
часу в
соціальних мережах, я думаю, що іноді краще, що
мої діти мають  їх
особисті блоки, і вони надсилають мені відео
на перевірку, і я сидів з одним відео, а
потім перевірив друге, третє
, і я знову припинив, тому перевірка
відео також важлива протягом дня,
і іноді це займає весь мій час
багато часу так чудово дуже гарні
відео на YouTube та інші відео дуже
добре, а як щодо друзів, що
щодо невеликих переговорів, так, так, ми
зовсім забули про друзів я спілкуюся в
Інтернеті зі своїми друзями я знову використовую
різні соціальні зв’язки
а як щодо перевірки
електронної пошти, чи є у вас певний час, коли
ви це робите протягом дня, чи я перевіряю це
випадковим чином, коли у мене сповіщення все
добре, дуже добре іноді вони отримували
сповіщення з моїх соціальних мереж, що
вони отримали повідомлення та  вони перестали
перевіряти потік, і вони можуть зупинитися
знову, так що скільки часу ви можете витратити на
соціальні мережі так само, як година занадто добре
, добре, добре
тож нехай це буде за кермом, іноді вони можуть
проводити багато часу в спортивному залі
, так що трафік добре, що ви
зазвичай робите, коли ви застрягли в
пробці, це залежить від мого настрою,
іноді я відповідаю на свої електронні листи, які перевірив
у своєму  друзі я перевіряю свою маму, тому я
переглянув відео, так гарне, що
твій день повний у соціальних мережах
tik-tok відео зображення натхнення маленькі
чати, які займають досить багато часу,
Наталія, тепер у вас все ще є ці
важливі речі, які добре спробуйте виправити  їх
у твій день, схоже, це
не впишеться так готування так, який
кулінарний кулінарний кулінарний кулінарний план добре, молодець, так,
ти встиг трохи попрацювати, давайте
з нашим спортом це не важливо,
мабуть,
батьки намагаються виправити твої батьки батьки
що  мої діти діти діти діти так у вас ще
є ваш так ваш час ваш час мені
час так це важливо спорт ви
вибираєте ви маєте вибрати я маю
вибрати так я вибираю вашого чоловіка або
спорт правда добре я візьму брата мого
чоловіка добре можу  це спорт із моїм
серцем, схоже, що лев приходить,
ефективно сплануй мій день, ти можеш зробити що
завгодно з цією ольгою, так, дозволь мені поділитися
з вами технікою, яку я
навчився деякий час тому, і насправді
пластикові блоки настільки візуальні, що  Я був
дуже добре вражений, тому давайте спробуємо в
неділю ввечері посидіти з
нотатками в телефоні або зі своїм щоденником, ви можете спланувати
свій тиждень заздалегідь, подумавши про те, що
для вас важливо, що для вас важливо, я
бачу правильно, тому, звичайно, я б поставила свого
чоловіка  у моїй родині добре проводжу час із ними,
чи дивишся фільм разом, чи
збираєшся разом гуляти, тоді спорт
ти знаєш, якщо ти плануєш це у своєму щоденнику,
ти робиш це, ти не пропускаєш
це наступна річ, наш домашній курс, ти
не можеш кинути їх  це те, що ви повинні
зробити, і якщо ви цього не зробите, ніхто інший
не зробить це правильно, тоді
час для мене може бути часом спокою,
коли я дійсно слухаю музику, яка мені подобається,
або читаю книгу або  просто
гуляю сам зі своїми  думки хороші
батьки так, ми повинні піклуватися про своїх
батьків і підтримувати з ними
регулярний зв'язок, як ви вже згадали, чому в
присутності та коли поставили їм цілі або
надіслали фотографії та відео ваших дітей,
вони б це оцінили,
я погоджуюсь, хороші діти так, дуже важливо
нижче вони займають багато часу, і якщо ви
не плануєте щось робити зі своїми
дітьми, вони будуть неслухняні, і ви не
будете почувати себе щасливими, наступний блок -
робота, так, робота займає багато часу до
восьми годин на день
однак, як ви вже згадували, підготовка
до ваших робочих завдань займає більше часу,
ніж хобі, у вашому випадку, коли я готувала їжу,
у моєму випадку, це буде гра на
фортепіано, що мені дуже подобається, тому у вас
є розклад важливих речей,
давайте виберемо це, щоб ви їх посадили
заздалегідь, і тепер вам все одно потрібно перевіряти
електронну пошту, і ви будете відволікатися
на різні відео,
акаунти в соціальних мережах або термінові телефонні дзвінки, тож чи
плануєте ви їх заздалегідь, чи що
ви з ними робите?  використовуйте, у вас
заплановані всі інші важливі частини вашого життя, вони є у вашому розкладі,
вони є у вашому тижневому розкладі, наприклад,
займаєтесь спортом, проводите час із сім'єю,
батьки планують щось заздалегідь
працювати, ці речі все одно залишаться тут,
але вони не завадять вам робити
що для вас важливо я бачу так,
трохи так, ви хотіли б побачити,
як це працює так, звичайно,
добре, тому це соціальні мережі, це можуть
бути невеликі переговори з моїми колегами,
які мені дуже подобаються, але це може бути
красиво  зображення шукати в
мережі ідеї слухати додаткову музику
дивитися серйозніше, що ви
планували не один, а десять хороших, це
може бути додатковий капучино з вашим
колегою, кожне може бути час на дорогу, що
вимагає часу і забирає вам багато нервів,
а я все ще маю трохи  час, що залишився для моїх
соціальних мереж, я бачу вас, і вони бачать, що
це насправді ідеально вписується у ваш
день так добре
, схоже, це ідеальна
техніка управління часом, яку ви можете спланувати
Спочатку важливі речі, а потім додаткові
речі, які будуть неактуальними,
все ще можуть вміститися без будь-яких проблем,
так, ви маєте рацію, фантастичні, тому я сподіваюся,
що починаючи з сьогоднішнього дня ви збираєтеся
планувати свій день заздалегідь і ефективно планувати свою планету
, щоб залишатися уважними
правильно, ти повинен бути присутнім у
даний момент і допоможи мені, будь ласка, багатокутники так,
ти повинен знати, що зараз я студент,
я зосереджуюся на своїх завданнях, я маю на увазі
з друзями, і я можу розважатися зі
своїми друзями, тепер це моє хобі  і мені
дуже подобається це робити, тому що якщо ви спробуєте
зробити домашнє завдання, щоб поспілкуватися зі своїм
другом і послухати пісню, яка вам
подобається, вас ніде немає так, я
повністю погоджуюся з вами, тому
дуже дякую вам за урок і
дякую  щоб приєднатися до нас сьогодні, не забувайте
про своє домашнє завдання, ваше
домашнє завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб вивчити слова та
скласти з ними красиві речення
дуже дякую до побачення дякую до побачення
[Музика]
ти